[Music]
yeah dude why do you why do you keep
doing that
you killed why do you kill the music
when we come out
I think uh you know what I I know why
it's a mistake from uh when we did the
uh live feed last week it's like the
energy dies in the room bro lay off my
man Dan you know he's he's really sad
the president is the real American
president is under Fire by the corrupt
district attorney Alvin Bragg in New
York I mean
we don't say his name yeah we are all
domestic terrorists
honestly honestly I thought we were all
domestic terrorists on this broadcast I
thought our fandom you know the the real
Maga heads I thought we we had a
momentum going and this week showed me
that there is no momentum behind the
mega movement there was like more
anti-trump people protesting outside of
the DA's uh office to like I guess
arrest him more they've been then there
were Mega people defending him they took
the fattest L's all week non-stop the
whole conservative movement uh in uh
Iowa was it
no Wisconsin Supreme Court elections uh
happened narrowly won and boy this was a
big one because that state Republican
best state is gerrymander to Hell freaks
dude that state is gerrymandered to Hell
there's a majority of Democrats in the
state but like Democrats will win like
60 of the vote right and then the state
legislature is like literally like 85
Republican it's it's the most insane
thing well but things like that could
potentially be uh dealt with by way of
the Supreme Court which was uh
originally a conservative majority and
now there will be a liberal majority so
that was a big dub in Wisconsin where
was it where Brandon Johnson a Chicago
Teachers Union yeah uh socialist one the
mayor of Chicago yeah yeah that was huge
love that we love to see that also Rand
Ron DeSantis um he uh was exposed for
grooming children this week wait really
oh I I was I'm waiting
I'm just wondering
it would not be surprising but remember
as Mega Republicans it's okay when we do
it okay remember when a white guy does
it even an Italian one like Ronda santis
um you know we'll allow it as long as
they're conservative their grooming is
fine that's called Traditional Values
like child marriages child Brides that's
Traditional Values
yeah I was good I noticed so what the
conservatives have been up to this week
was uh passing a bill and I forget which
state which allows uh I guess teachers
or I don't know who the [__] is
volunteering for this inspection day to
inspect children's genitals to ensure
that Ohio and now I think uh Kansas I
think it was our Kansas and I will I'm
just curious oh it's just Kansas
standards Kansas you know I'm just
curious so yeah so they say we must
ensure that there's no trans people
participating in sports for the fairness
to ensure the fairness of Middle School
volleyball don't Google it is Kansas
Kansas is a feckless cowardly Democratic
governor uh who vetoed this and then of
course they overrode that veto in the
state legislature again they have the
numbers in both the House of
Representatives in the state senate
um don't look this number up how many
trans athletes exist in the state of
Kansas
I mean it's got to be close to zero just
give me just give me a give me a number
any number well like so when you say
trans athlete you mean professional
athlete no just from K through 12 just
any person until the Collegiate level
updates in sports which is what this
Bill yes this bill pertains to penis
inspection days and vagina inspection
days for literally children like all the
way from kindergarten to 12th grade so
in that regard I see you typing Ethan
don't know no no no
uh oh yeah you're you're asking
something else but gosh I don't know I
mean that's a huge swath of people I
mean what maybe I don't know
I'll tell you the actual number 106 000
students I think or it might even be
more than that that are participating in
athletic competitions in the state of
Kansas that's the that's all the whole
pool that's the entire pool of people if
you've got to be an athletic student
athletic competition it's got to be less
than 50 then 50 less less than well I
keep saying you're not giving it to me I
say five five would you be shocked if I
told you it was 10
uh no not at all I said five well guess
what I was lying it's actually two it's
actually I was lying again I mean I feel
like I won this game it was actually
three and two of them are graduating
this year so it only leaves one trans
girl in the state of Kansas that they're
doing the penis inspection Day show
there's gonna be like dudes just hey hey
bring those genitals over here a little
exactly you're gonna have CIS girls like
that are [__] dominating I guess in
some field right it'll be like the swim
meet or whatever and you're gonna have
the perverted fathers waiting outside
being like that team they got they got
them Trans in that team go we need I
want to check their uh vaginas like
that's literally so what's so [__]
disgusting and cowardly and perverse I
mean obviously on face value it is all
that but in the meantime last week uh
they are talking about protecting
children from Gay and trans predators
editors while
by the way this is the guy who's
spearheaded this to inspect uh
transgenitals who so who's volunteering
is it him
yeah who's volunteering for that job you
know I would like to know their name and
their [__] and their place of birth
and also I would like to know their
criminal history it's very interesting
Jared from Subway is he the inspector
it's very interesting that you mentioned
that because I looked through the bill I
read the bill and I couldn't find a
single area in the bill that talked
about like potentially having a medical
professional do it they literally they
talk more about like stopping the harm
and when I thought harm I was like oh
like they're trying to at least like
soften the blow by you know writing
extensively about like medical
professionals that will potentially do
this like a physical or whatever nope
they meant harm is in like having a 12
year old trans girl competing a swimming
that's the harm that they're trying to
eliminate we must we must maintain the
competitive sake sacred competitiveness
of Middle School swim meets
yeah and therefore I volunteer to
inspect
also it doesn't even have to be trans
person it could be anyone they suspect
of yeah no no that's that's what I'm
saying so it could be hey little boy you
train you look at the little Trends now
let me take a look at that little penis
he always make sure you ain't trans or
nothing that's my point this is what the
Bible says they can do that this is what
a lot of us don't understand a lot of
people do not understand this reality
that like there aren't that many trans
people on the planet in general okay
there are significantly more CIS
athletes competing in these athletic
competitions this just allows psychotic
oftentimes maybe pedophilic parents to
to you know harass your daughters harass
your sons for the crime of competing
well
you know have fun with that Kansas
this is the Kansas house Speaker Daniel
Hawkins uh who just passed the new
anti-lgbtq bill
um I'm sure that this bill will not be
uh exploited by anybody no no definitely
not it's export free it will not well I
think the whole thing is Expo I don't
think it can be used
at all can you is it legal like can you
make a law that says kids have to show
you their junk like is that even a law
that you can make I mean it's a it's I
think it would be like a Fourth
Amendment violation yeah right it's but
also like
you know this guy seems real horny this
guy wants to see your kids Amendment
like unlawful search and seizure erosion
to privacy of a minor child predation
but then like one really horny
Republican state senator or state
legislator
I mean I hey little lady you looking a
little bit trans over there let me come
take a look now oh nope she's she's okay
she's sick she's just a normal girl all
right who's next oh come on over here
now little trans looking boy
yeah no they're they're just you know
Meanwhile by the way he just looks like
the type of dude who's upset that like
the Archdiocese of Baltimore got too
much action you know what I mean he's
like he's jealous why is it that only
why is it that only them Catholic
priests and archdiocese are having all
the fun with the young men and young
women I think we should also get in on
the on this piece of action don't get me
started with the church music sack
yeah what I'm of course referencing is
the the Archdiocese of Baltimore there's
like a 498 page uh investigation that
recently concluded that uh uh the
Maryland attorney general found that the
the Baltimore Catholic Church was just
doing rampant uh child predation
shocking so this was coming out at the
same time right and I can't emphasize
just enough how the conservatives are
they're out here trying to prevent kids
from being preyed upon and I didn't see
any one of them talking about this
massive cover-up in Maryland uh just
another and a long list of a more than
150 50 Catholic priests and other
associates of the Archdiocese of
Baltimore sexually abused over 600
children bro it's like an often escaped
accountability if you don't sexually
abuse a child they like make fun of you
they're like this guy doesn't even want
to [__]
um doesn't want to abuse children
with you straight up canceled for saying
a few years ago that the Catholic church
is basically as close to like sanctioned
like pedophiles like they're just it's
like an organization of pedophiles four
pedophiles and you know listen here it
is again 150 priests in the state that's
a whole organized effort to [__] kids
600 of them dude and often escaped
accountability this is like you know
what the Catholic church is and you know
what you're gonna get mad at me and
that's fine the church the church did
this to themselves I didn't do [__]
[__] I didn't touch any goddamn kids
I'll tell you what have you ever the
church is a
pedophilia they are pedophilia first and
then they do like some God and community
service second that's like but like the
point is so that we can [__] kids right
but then the secondary is so that we can
like
make it look like we're not just here to
[__] kids yeah but also that's the
Catholic church but also you know
trans people exists my counter to is
that like there are trans people out
there who are you know wearing
programmer socks and and playing Hearts
of Iron so that's pretty terrifying is a
proposition I'm curious so this was uh
let's see the report paints a damning
picture of the Archdiocese which is the
oldest Roman Catholic Diocese in the
country some parishes schools and
congregations had more than one abuser
at the same time
so what's up let that sink in bro they
weren't even they weren't even like uh
spreading territorially they were just
like like so what what happens is
they're just like when when one is like
abusing a child the other one's like yo
chill bro this is my [__] Turf like
no they like I'm the one no us they
strategize look out no [__] straight
up dude they are working together to
make this more enterprising for them it
was there was this huge uh the last one
that came out which state was that in
with like the massive one uh with the a
similar thing with chip with uh just uh
you might be thinking of Massachusetts I
mean there's been several though so so
there was another one where there was
multiple
um
multiple priests and other associates
they would mark
the [__]
choir boys or whatever the church boys
with special jewelry so that the other
Predators knew that they were easy prey
that they had already been groomed they
gave them a special gold cross what the
[__] that's what I'm saying y'all cannot
[__] tell me [__] about pedophiles
being anywhere else in Pennsylvania area
yeah you cannot [__] tell me a
goddamn thing about abusers being
anywhere else in society when y'all
sending your kids to church every Sunday
they're getting molested and they have
to live in Pennsylvania That's like
[__] so terrible the holy spirit it's
just the
that was 300 priests this one is well
actually yeah this one's 150 so shout
out yeah week numbers for Maryland step
it up oh Maryland's pretty small state
there Maryland's like we got to get
these numbers up per capita Pennsylvania
is cooking us with child molestation
Bro [__] the Catholic Church anyway
um so yeah you know interesting eventful
week so far we got a lot going on uh I
see you wearing
a very interesting shirt oh Ethan on
well done it's hard to it's hard to move
past the hypocrisy of this yeah like
there's actually child predators and
they want to talk about the one trans
girl so we can look at their dick dude
they're all predators yeah well
regardless anyway yeah Godzilla I see
you wearing this this Godzilla dress
which is thanks bro you know I mean I
don't know if you know this but they
called they call me Godzilla in Japan
you would like that I knew you would
like I'm just saying like it's kind of
like like I didn't even know this drop
was coming out you didn't even tell me
even like I'm kind of like the
Ambassador
well here tell me what you like so uh
this just came out uh just at 10 A.M
this is my fave if I I'm just gonna say
it go ahead I don't often uh you know
use terminology like this
if I don't get
okay if I don't get the Godzilla the the
the the
bowling t-shirt the the the camp shirt
this one's amazing I wore it yesterday
yeah if I don't get that shirt okay I'm
quitting this vodka all right uh okay
amazing who's it can you someone run
that message down to uh yeah I got it oh
you know you're here okay good good good
yeah I don't need a triple X Ultra black
so it might be too big I'll I'll test it
I'll test the waters with double XL
because I've been getting too skinny
okay I wore that XL yesterday and it was
yeah I think the 2XL might be okay for
you yeah because the triple XL was a
little too big the baggy poplin pants
look sick too I don't know what's going
on one remaining love
I just clicked it it says one remaining
try to add it
I got it
hold on
maybe one got canceled a quarter got
canceled or something right sorry uh
yeah I like the gray I like the gray
problem pants but you don't have to buy
it just tell I mean it'll get soil out
first but someone could grab it the gray
pants which one we talking about
pants yeah dude this bike jersey looks
oh this one God damn it the baggy
popping pants yeah and I want the
button-up shirt
what size for those the button-up shirt
I'd like a triple X Outlet possible but
wait what is this one I wear this too
much Ethan wait which button-up shirt
now I'm confused oh this one okay okay
so this one's a triple XL but you guys
are triple XL sold out
I mean I'll try it on I'll try the
double XL on with it for the blue shirt
this one seems a little oversized maybe
I don't know I don't know it's not it's
not it's usually I didn't re-exl sell
out that's crazy
they're like I don't know you gotta
there's there's people out there in the
[__] Teddy fresh fandom that's that's
they have it out for me
and I don't like that do you want this
cool ass biker Jersey
dude it looks [__] sick it is sick
yeah I want it oh wait no it's only an
XL no that's fine that's supposed to be
super form-fitting it's a biker Jersey
oh okay you know what you're doing yeah
I don't know if is this a women's tee I
thought yeah we might have downstairs
yeah I'll check for that this is my fave
shirt this shirt is so sick dude
so [__] dope I was gonna wear it
again but I was like I can't be walking
around the same shirt all the time yeah
I know it's sick oh my God that Fire
tied to Yo throw that fire tie in there
too the time oh it's sold out [__]
bro no no no not that one the fire oh
the fire tie the fire tie
oh this one yeah you got that Lena
yeah I got it I don't have any ties like
I've been wearing more suits lately
every time I
uh what do you call it every time Trump
gets like arraigned oh yeah I've seen I
just wear a suit I love that to
celebrate it you know the whole like
at my at my wedding I'm wearing pajama
pants but it trumps a Raymond I'm
wearing a suit that kind of [__]
everything to me and honestly
um I I realized like I have to wear
bolos all the time because I just don't
own any type well not anymore
yeah you have a badass flame tie sure uh
this is also one of my faves just really
nice yeah so Godzilla that was fun bro
throw that in there triple XL you got
that Lena
and then for the um
what size
for the wood the bag
oh the largest one are these women's are
they unisex
oh it's all unisex okay what do I know
I'll try them on too to see if they
they're like actually bagging on me it
says XL to 2XL that's a big spread boy
okay there it goes so thank you thank
you so guys teddyfresh.com
Godzilla collection is up now it's so
fun it's so great we love me some
Godzilla all about the respect well yeah
I've become a dirty outfit repeater like
I'm constantly I'm constantly wearing
this the the teddy fresh uh black denim
tea or the black denim shirt I'm glad
you like it man yeah very happy all
right so we have so much to get to
um let's see
oh I got a update no button for a moment
had to turn it off
wait what button oh I love that they
have to I don't have a button more
button yeah you're freeballing right I
thought be careful I thought you were
updating about something about the
clothing oh no no no no yeah oh there's
no button okay [__]
did that do anything
no okay
um hopefully that doesn't break the
stream
um so
um speaking of breaking the stream how
about breaking out of prison Andrew Tate
that's such a bad segue I don't know why
I'm doing this no it's a good segue
whatever better than most of ours Andrew
Tate's out of prison and of course uh
what is he doing with his uh Newfound
Freedom he's posting thirst traps like a
goddamn body oh this is the gayest video
ever okay first of all I just gotta say
well that is of course a constant like
there is something very uh
I guess soy or whatever about uh the way
Andrew Tate carries himself if you want
to call it that I don't know he is very
zesty but
um you know there's nothing there's
nothing more uh you know Godly and
god-like and and enlightened and getting
out of prison and then immediately uh
retweeting and like posting share
themselves you're smoking a cigar and
then like uh you know talking about how
your enemies are gay
this this was a fan edit that he
retweeted yeah just I watched this and I
was like I have yet to see this so I'm
very excited I was like bro am I watched
this almost seems like
this is like straight up gay pornography
I mean it really is and that's that's
just I don't know I was in jail I did 7
417 push-ups
oh I love the the numerology in the
Quran is my favorite type of [__] from
like my turkey days you know what I mean
like I love oh God that's so dumb it's
it's one of the dumbest things it's my
favorite it's like
what did that Surah say I don't even
know they just kind of pointed to it I
don't know anything I'll be revealed I
don't know nothing about nobody it's a
prison house for a Believer
oh yeah he included both of us and my
fat ass eating a hamburger or something
Have you never done a drag what I'm
surprised you've never done drag have
you yeah yes oh I went oh they just
haven't found it yet that's why they
always put you like fat yeah that's my
thing yeah I'm fat oh you're gay they've
found yeah I I I've done I've done uh
direct the funniest thing is like I look
so [__] good
like every time they post that every
time they post the photo there's like
two different photos with three photos
of me on three separate occasions uh one
is like they could have gone for me oh
you're you're giving it to them now they
would they couldn't even take the beta
now yeah they know I look good the thing
is I look just so talking about it like
in that in that uh in that video that
they show I look so [__] brolic like
I love that one they whenever they post
it I'm like dude what are you talking
about yeah you look I look [__] yoke
look at the size of those yeah look at
those my gumbos dude I mean I got all
right well hold on dude I got some Nancy
Pelosi's on me okay
stop playing dude oh see those titties
you're like those are suckable okay okay
I'm wearing the gloves I this is from
when I went to hot ones and ate the
world's hottest hamburger like why pull
that one anyone could have done that but
okay I think they're just like they were
like Ethan Klein eating like that's it
to make like that's all you need
anything you don't even like you you
look good in that you don't look fat in
that like you don't even just biting
into a hamburger at this point they're
not even everybody knows that I'm the
fat guy yeah like that's that's pretty
epic damn is that you yeah that was
Frenemies man holy [__] brother bro you
look
you look like you'd be a Barb organ at
Sephora I look like a straight [__] doll
you look hot thank you you look you look
sexy a lot of people were feeling it
yeah that's crazy but anyway okay get
your dicks out because this is when the
compilation gets good this is this is
Dicks out dicks out oh desapitate
ABS exercising boxing abs
7417 yeah no that's yeah that's so is a
prison for a Believer and a paradise for
the disbeliever oh okay yeah wait is but
what does that make how does that make
sense what's the relevancy it's a
paradise for the disbeliever it's saying
you guys are the disbelievers and he was
in prison because he's a believer
he's showing you guys like having fun I
guess and then he's he's a Believer and
he's in prison I believe it well that
was kind of an L isn't it I know I don't
get that it sounds like disbelief is the
is that's the way to go I'm all about it
yeah but uh when I was in jail I did 7
417 push-ups foreign
I can't I love this whole uh you know
you want to know what the [__]
biggest cheat code is for guys straight
up is the beard he grew the beard out
and like now you can't see how [__]
chinless he is it's really wild and I
saw people thirsting after him when he
does look good with a beard I mean he
should definitely shave the head though
like it's very obvious how bald he is do
you the person who made this wants to
[__] him there's like no question about
it like why are you so obsessed with his
abs yeah like what does that have to do
with him being like
innocent I think that's what so so this
man was the case of sex trafficking but
check out his own ABS yeah the the kid
who made this living in like
where would be where would be like a
good not turkey I would say like this is
maybe like a golf State kid you know
what I mean who's like who's like been
to England and stuff and you know loves
traveling uh upper middle I mean wealthy
okay he made this compilation because he
himself is in a mind prison that my
prison is that he has you know these
constant uh thoughts of of wanting to
suck and [__] Andrew Tate
that's why he's in a mine prison we on
the other hand are are gay and therefore
uh fat and gay yeah we're free we're
free to enjoy the world that's what he's
saying yo so you're gay I I heard about
this clip and I haven't seen it and I'm
so excited to watch this this is
interest both of us Waka Flocka friend
of the show Flocka went on
fresh and fit and he was so repulsed by
them he walked out
this sounds amazing amazing amazing so
let's say something yeah now that you
are acknowledging the existence of fresh
and fair amazing the bald one is going
to be doing like
3 A.M gym sessions
thinking about us again he has never oh
yeah have you ever seen those posts he's
always a [__] phone what is this
title what do you mean juicer politics
app trumpy dumpy arrested Civil War on
the horizon
it's a it is kind of a vibe to be honest
you like it I like it I was trying to
get some feedback on the title this
morning wasn't here anything and then I
threw this one out as a joke and
everybody liked it so I just threw it on
okay so I do like it but I know that
YouTube does not like gratuitous use of
emojis I like it yeah wait really that's
what I saw them say that they says only
use emojis only very very brawl uh
slightly YouTube also keeps like you
don't like it YouTube also keeps like
age restricting all my [__] content
because they say suck my dick or
whatever really yeah they're like this
is nudity language
um our uh band again our podcast nice is
you're still up
um I don't know I think like Austin's
been too busy working for the whole town
that little [__] so uh he hasn't really
been uploading he is good man he hasn't
really been uploading any [__] tick
tocks
lately so that's a problem it's our home
and that's why socialism doesn't work
bro because you're giving them like a
cut and he's cruising around he's like
okay I'll take a cut from everybody yeah
it's [__] up that's right for
capitalism time to get capitalism on
your boy yeah I'm gonna go capitalist on
his ass that's what I'm saying anyway
here I've been I've been uh really
excited to watch this so so let's see it
tell people they're stupid anymore we
need to go back to bullying people
letting them know no that's not really
how the world works you sound dumb
change your my way of thinking but we
don't bully people no more and tell them
they're dumb yeah I agree with you
either but let's stop for that yeah but
like you know who who do you think is
gonna get bullied in that world dog is
you first of all change the camera angle
brother you've been sitting you've been
sitting there for the longest time
everybody sees how hard you're crowning
change the [__] camera angle
why why does he sit in front of that
camera and it just like beams directly
to the top of his Dome what's going on
there
again living a very pussified Society
where everyone thinks what they say is
okay I appreciate that's ridiculous I
agree with that I agree more bullying I
agree where do they find these people
also Instagram I don't really follow the
logic there nobody tells people they're
dumb anymore I think the point is not
like a thing people don't disagree
anymore or they can't be like okay
that's stupid and I don't have to listen
to you or it's like hey I believe in
trans Reds and it's like God get kill
them I feel like people say and do that
nothing's changed every day people are
the same all day nothing's changed
nothing's changed that's what I was
saying before I'm sorry I disagree bro
I'm gonna be honest [__] I'm a real
[__] right and I'll never make a woman
I don't give a [__] 100 what you say
hold something I'm respecting you on
your show you're on the wrong show dude
he's like yo what is this show
I mean y'all are talking about what why
the [__] that Waka Flocka go on this
podcast
he's like wait wait wait wait wait wait
what's this podcast about [__] he seems
like a nice guy by all accounts I don't
understand what has happened
of course because you got an opinion I'm
a real [__] okay that's cool I'm
telling you right now I don't give a
[__] what she said she would I'm
different from you
he's right and he's wrong for a fact
this is a whole group of other men that
don't feel like it but he right that's
the way men in the past used to think
but like like like like like everything
else you got to transition you have to
evolve with your opinions some women
take go too far with that [__] and
that's why I got
my man on ice like it because women is
pulling oh no men make us feel sexy men
no that's [__] I'm telling you it's
[__] to the to the to the popular
demand you know what I'm trying to say
some people use these quotes and [__] to
their advantage to make money or to
advance in their career but I'm just
saying that but I just I disagree I
think when people say things that are
stupid they need to be called out man I
agree I agree you can say stupid [__]
I wonder if he came on for this did he
come on to confront him I don't know but
Waka Flocka graduated from the Bible
Institute of America with an honorary
professor's degree in humanitarianism
and uh whoa yeah and philanthropy wow
good Flocka we're the flockas at dude
there's a lot behind them flakkas and he
graduated alongside
my goat Reverend Jesse Jackson wow yeah
Flocka is a brat is right
I like things like you got to call out
stupidity even if it's a man he's like
yo we need to be bullying your dumb ass
right now and he's right and that's kind
of what we do to be fair market Flocka's
life to Suicide Prevention and spreading
the message of suicide helpline since
the death of his younger brother rapper
in 2013. personal yeah he's like yo what
we need to do is bully people more this
dude's brother
unalived himself yeah he said he's
officially dedicating his life to
Suicide Prevention and mental illness
y'all not alone Waka Flocka Flame is
with y'all now
yo I love Waka Flocka
whoa dude this guy's real inner woman
because the thing is is that we live in
a world nowadays where we're scared to
correct women and tell them that that
was dumb you probably shouldn't say that
and right yeah it is what it is then
they get on the platform and embarrass
themselves in front of 30 000 people
hold on I gotta just note the coconuts
and Barbados here looking super engaged
in the conversation as always I don't
know if you guys can tell he's thinking
about uh sandy beaches and beautiful
coconuts and uh palm trees then they get
on a platform and embarrass themselves
in front of 30 000 people so my thing is
I think both genders need to be held
account oh my God look at that head Bro
Look at that Dome piece oh my Lord
listen I mean I'm not commenting on this
you know because all I'm gonna say is
this we all know why he's losing hair
because he's your he's a villain in the
in the Ethan verse and you're just
taking away his his I just took off my
[__] beanie what's up how old is
Myron
I think uh younger than me I think he
was Hassan's age if I recall I'm 37.
wait really he's my age
no he looks hurt 33. dude what the [__]
he looks younger then oh wait he looks
like wait how old is he actually I'm
seeing different reports some 35 I'm
seeing mostly from Keith bro he looks
like he's got mileage on him that's
crazy
God damn just hating women
profession is just like
this man's 35 he's like a fully grown
man at this point fan women for clear
skin okay for first thick hair and forth
and women for thick hair yeah it doesn't
always work yeah I also yeah also stand
twice all right let me let me hear what
flock has got young is my bias honorable
regardless
is it easier for a woman to get laid or
a man to get laid I think it's both
incorrect yeah I just said earlier one
in three years
you know what's awesome about this wait
pause for a second I know we just
unpause it but it's like these are like
conversations that I had like when I was
a child you know what I mean when I was
like 14 I was like dude it's like way
easier for girls to get laid like stupid
oh my God and then but he's like a whole
ass adult having this like 14 year old
ass conversation
with with the with the seriousness of
like debating I don't know [__]
abortion laws or something like it's
like yeah women are actually
statistically proven to be uh a lot
easier to to get laid they have this
same conversation every episode yeah and
people can't get enough of it they're
like [__] yeah dude please talk about
them be like women get laid more easy
than men and next week we'll talk about
how women get laid more easy than men
yeah 30. there's women that are virgins
hold on real quick by choice
[Music]
[Applause]
I really want to know how
he ended up there but good for him like
that for him I just I don't understand
like they titled this like Waka Flocka
confronted Myron's facts and this
happened
um they're gonna try to [__] on welcome
I mean that's from like March 21st bro
you guys are looking real you guys are
looking like stance right now I'm not
gonna lie you you posted this video from
like [__] month ago
on here
just saying wait they posted this no
this is a
this is a uh
a a older video this is from like the OG
video I just clicked on the on what is
this from March
21st oh that's not that old goddamn I
thought you're saying two weeks ago man
two weeks ago Barbados pocket now I'll
do it coconuts and Barbados yeah it's
crazy the replies are all saying that
like Myron held his ground L for Wako
what what made it
come on now man here we go come on
[Music]
no there there are a lot of I've just
come to
to recognize the reality that there are
a lot of dudes out there that have like
the IQ of a plankton you know what I
mean it's just it is what it is and
they're not gonna change you know
let's talk about politics because we
don't we're gonna get all caught up on
this Waka Flocka call it politics I call
it polit tricks okay dolly
[Music]
well just speaking of politics here's a
high and the shovel potentially high
back on crack Mike Lindell begging for
money no he would be way cooler if he
was on crack well I don't know about
that this is this man looks like he's
the only one who's the only one who's
become worse after recovering also what
do you mean he gained like 30 pounds you
think he's on crack what are you crazy
cracker uh he's on something let me show
you and we're still doing we still have
some of those all-season slippers left
at 25 a pair to thank all of you out
there uh for the great uh for supporting
us supporting us through all this my
employees we've lost all our box stores
our shopping channels uh we get attacked
every single day and my pillow should
not have to be attacked when they're
protecting companies out there that we
never heard the names of before which I
don't need to name all the voting
machine companies but and as they say if
you go woke you go bro bro Dominion is
clearing this man yeah bro Dominion
honestly like uh the the entire business
of of like election vote counting
machines relies on confidence and like
the concert the the the effort that Mike
Lindell basically almost single-handedly
spearheaded that even Fox News took on
until they realized O'Shea we're about
to get [__] sued into Oblivion
uh is is coming back to haunt these
people yeah Dominion came out and is
suing everybody and
Mike's in like a 94 Honda Accord out in
like the middle of the [__] deserts
of Las Vegas yeah he's just [__] man
like guys I just I just robbed the
liquor store uh used the code mic pillow
I need help for my legal counsel I don't
pay for it we don't have anything left
guys but we made a special deal he goes
to thank you that's my favorite question
and we're still doing we showed some of
those all-season slippers left at 25
appearance please buy these we've got
our flippers season slippers it just
says a special favor to thank you guys
25 a piece you know what he looks like
he look what the [__] was that I don't
know what Twitter blue check mark at or
something wait what that just pop up
yeah
um he he looks like that one Trump guy
who like
said that he had bombs in his car and
like drove his car to the Capitol
do you guys remember that yeah and he
was like I'm begging I'm I'm praying I'm
praying to Trump right now I'm praying
to Trump right now please save me and
then like his window gets busted in by
the cop yeah yeah like on the live
stream that's what he looks like he
looks like this is Mom sorry he's like
moments before disaster well here's a
bet here this version makes a little
more sense uh somebody made this edit
here Jesse
[Music]
for the great uh
from all this my employees
[Music]
attacked every single day and my bill s
should not have to be attacked with a
protective companies out there
[Music]
yeah eyes on the road he's not looking
too good I'm not gonna lie but that's
what happens when you throw when you
pitch Your Wagon to Trump I mean look at
Rudy Giuliani this man is a [__] dude
please pull that clip of him on Fox News
which one Rudy he's talking about I sent
it in chat
it's him when he was talking about how
uh Trump
anal paid off
oh yeah it's Army but it wasn't illegal
it's in the dock later here I'll grab it
it's so [__] good now under the scope
that obviously Trump just got arrested
for disgusting 34 felonies of uh of uh
falsifying business records
and the in the you know conspiracy to
pay off Stormy Daniels and this clip of
Rudy Giuliani again another
um
another guy who was successful in life
very successful who decided to pitch his
wagon to Trump who's now I mean hitch
hitches yeah
but uh I mean he was very successful but
like they were these guys were always
clowns like that's the other thing
Lindell was like 100 millionaire
and now he's like doing crap yes bro God
now he's like I look super rich he's
smoking crack in the [__] deserts of
God damn we don't know we don't know if
he's doing crack he just but he does not
look good
now watch this clip and just realize how
amazing this is now that Trump's been
arrested can you do with paying some
Stormy Daniels woman 130 000 I mean
which is going to turn out to be
perfectly legal so that money was not
campaign money I do it all the time like
he's like admitting he did it back then
yeah you a fact now that you don't know
it's not campaign money
no
campaign Finance violation so they
funneled it through the law firm
funnel through offer and the president
repaid it
I didn't know he did yeah there's no
campaign Finance law zero
just like every Sean so what this
decision was made by everybody everybody
was nervous about this from the very
beginning I wasn't I this man is insane
well I mean this is a part of their
defense for the record this is a part of
their defense now
so I don't know exactly when Rudy was
talking about this but like this was
it's all out there so like yeah they did
they did pay Stormy Daniels like they're
openly admitting that at the time they
were trying to deny that it was even
happened yeah now they've moved on
because like see this is the the the
bouldering effect of Donald Trump where
he does so much extra
illegal or you know awful business
practices that it basically is hard to
like tackle one aspect of it because
like originally people were like oh
let's not you know the the Stormy
Daniels thing is a lie it's fake it's
not real whatever
but because of all the other stuff that
he did in the process of like trying to
bury the story it doesn't even matter
anymore they're like yeah it was real
but it was not illegal right you know
they just and just I like he's
eventually Trump will perjure himself
and then they'll say well you know he
perjured himself here but in the in the
court case there was nothing wrong there
was no illicit dealings dude he's going
we were all super worried about this
but I wasn't nervous about this from the
very beginning I wasn't I knew how much
money Donald Trump put into that
campaign I said 130 000. you're going to
do a couple of checks for 130 000. when
I heard uh Cohen's uh retainer of 35 000
when he was doing no work for the
president I said that's how he's
repaying that's how he's repaying it why
what wait no that's that's actually
that's what happened okay that is what
happened that is quite literally
like does Alvin Bragg know this video
exists
crazy it's nuts man no I looked through
the statement of facts on this it's so
funny like
in order for this to be anything but a
misdemeanor which is usually just a fine
other campaigns have done similar things
and they've literally paid fines for it
in order for this to to
become like a John Edwards style
situation
um there needs to be intent to uh to do
this specifically for the election and
the defense I mean that's like to prove
Beyond a reasonable doubt that you did
this with the express purpose of like
hiding information from electors
um
that's
usually hard to prove but of course
Donald Trump being [__] Donald Trump
uh and and refusing to pay people all
the time uh very clearly and openly
states to Michael Cohen don't pay Stormy
Daniels until after the election because
after the election no one like we're not
gonna I don't give a [__] if the story
comes out no no no no no no no no so
basically this is like an impossible in
every other circumstance it's pretty
much an impossible case to [__]
convict someone on except Donald Trump
has given them enough evidence so we'll
see how it works I mean ultimately it's
still like not that big of an issue it's
not that big of a deal they're not wrong
when they say it uh
in the state of New York businesses get
away with like a a boatload worse uh and
more illicit things but
uh you know it's fun it's funny it is
funny with a little profit and a little
margin for paying taxes for Michael but
do you know the president didn't know
about this
as far as I know but he did know about
the general Arrangement that Michael
would take care of things like this like
I take care of things like this for my
the idea this man is [__] nuts yeah
someone look at it someone look at Rudy
giuliani's dealings it seems
he thinks you say you do this
interesting I do it all the time I've
done it so many times you don't
understand here's my favorite thing to
do I'm doing it right now here's a story
about uh justice Chief or not Chief just
but a Supreme Court Justice Clarence
Thomas his wife famously is a
absolute well Curtis Thomas is a freak
too he's like
Clarence Thomas weirdly enough doesn't
get enough coverage on like his insane
world view he's very hard to fit into a
box
uh in in like American ideology he is in
many respects in my opinion a perfect
demonstration of like the the the often
uh contradicting and conflicting uh
political opinions that can exist in one
mind one beautiful legal scholarly mind
uh where he's like
he's like very anti-black obviously but
also simultaneously kind of pro-black
it's like almost like a like a black
separatist
well his wife is a trump truther yeah I
mean his wife is crazy the election was
stolen and all this [__] and I don't
know I can't imagine that these two go
home and don't be talking about uh how
the election was stolen well I mean we
know for a fact that he was the only one
who uh what was it did not want to what
was the Trump thing that Clarence Thomas
like actually ruled against the the rest
of the Supreme Court on
um was it was related to the January 6th
stuff yeah right people wanted him to
recuse himself and he was just like nah
right because he came out his wife yeah
there was a there was a glaringly
obvious conflict of interest uh
in in the uh January 6 situation so what
anyway it just came out that Justin
Justice Clarence has secretly accepted
luxury trips from major Republican
donors newly obtained documents and
interviews show the extent and frequency
of these apparent gifts Thomas has no
known precedent and modern Supreme Court
history
uh I I by the way I call [__] on
that
like there's no [__] no that's that's
cap you really think that Supreme Court
Justices aren't getting [__] favors
like at least they're not like not one's
been uncovered this blatantly yeah the
Supreme Court you know ideally they're
supposed to be like this impartial group
that does isn't swayed by politics and
there certainly shouldn't be able to get
to them you know what I mean like that's
the whole point of the damn Supreme
Court so uh the funniest part is you
can't do anything about it they're just
they are unaccountable yeah they're just
completely untouched 100
unaccountable like they go Justice at
Clarence you should recuse yourself
because of your wife's nah nah
here he is Thomas has publicly presented
himself as an every man with modest
taste
but
that video is actually very funny here
he is presenting himself as an everyday
man
you know I don't have any problem with
going to Europe but I prefer the United
States yeah and I prefer seeing the
regular parts of the United States I
prefer going across the rural area sure
I love seeing me them RV camps ain't
nothing more picturesque than a lot full
of RVs there actually is something more
picturesque keep it playing
um I'll tell you what's real I prefer
the I'll tell you what's picturesque
that Clarence Thomas loves horse porn
does he watch horse porn
wait what does that mean what's the
what's the
if that man's watching the horsepower we
just j-r-h-n-br
don't ask me
I mean there was an entire uh there this
this was a big deal uh it was what it
was a big deal back in the day uh
Clarence Thomas before he was uh
appointed to the Supreme Court had
hearings just like everyone else does
and obviously uh there's the the famous
Anita Hill uh conversation that took
place uh Joe Brandon at the time as a
matter of fact uh pretty much defended
Clarence Thomas against Anita Hill
was The Whistleblower and uh one of the
things that Clarence Thomas was
um alleged to do in the office regularly
was talk about the types of pornography
that he was watching which included
bestiality no no no no no no no no no
this man this man was his horse bro
reality these people are [__] Greeks
dog yes
yeah I'm seeing it all reported that is
can I make this joke here again and Dan
and Hassan can I make this joke
thank you for checking since we don't
have the button at the moment
uh uh let's see
can I say that I mean that's you think
that's mean but I mean it's mean but
they just don't know I don't care okay
well I was gonna say
you know Justice Clarence if he watches
horse porn
then that explains uh
that sure explains it's really
delivering this that really explains his
choice and significant others see that
feels so mean really
but they but she I mean these are like
actual demons that's a woman right there
Ethan God damn homina homina homina
awuga Jenny Thomas that's a woman I
shouldn't have said that just the right
height she's not she's bigger than him
yeah as hell
she's just the rat more like Winnie
Thompson am I right well yeah because I
want to [__] up their animals because
horses they that horses win they go
so this man jerks off to bestiality like
to feed her bales of hay if you know
what I'm saying she's sexy
come on baby let me get on this bucket
now eh no bucket required
that's right it's just me and my wife
trying to overturn democracy yeah well I
want to watch this the RV parks I prefer
the Walmart parking lots too this man is
traveling America visiting Walmart
parking lots that's what I like to do
freak
nobody
dude can you actually Pander to that
level and people don't call you out I
travel the country visiting Walmart
parking lots
man of the people yeah for the Walmart
parking lots to the beaches and things
like that what bro it's like
it's like you went to Yale dog what the
[__] are you saying right yeah like what
are you saying obviously island hopping
in a private jet while this documentary
was being made yeah I love I love
Walmart parking lots and uh getting on
billionaires private jets you know a lot
of my colleagues like to use them fancy
Japanese uh bidets I personally like to
use the public restrooms at McDonald's
and stuff type like that man it's just
like it's so strange when these guys do
this kind of like
this kind of LARPing you know that's why
they're like yeah
normal to me about it I've come from
regular stock Yale and I prefer that I
prefer being around them
all right so so meanwhile back on the
ranch uh justice Thomas's friend with as
friendship with dallas-based real estate
magnet Harlan Crowe has allowed him to
repeatedly experience luxuries well
beyond his means his vacation on Crows
162 Foot super yacht what
around the globe and flies on his uh on
his private jet
uh this man is cruising on a super yacht
talking about Walmart parking lots the
[__] Thomas boarded Crow's private jet
to Indonesia for nine days of island
hopping on his yacht had Thomas uh
chartered the Jet and Yacht himself it
could have cost him over 500k more than
that
it blows my mind like a dude that's from
you know dude that was born in 1948
in Georgia
to a family where his dad left at the
age of two and is like [__] they were
homeless and [__] could be such a
gross psychopath with with a glaring
disdain for
for all marginalized people and and poor
people in general he's like he's the
perfect demonstration of like I got mine
[__] you yes that's what some people
they tend to when they come from like
abject poverty or horrible conditions
you know it can either it can either
give you more empathy or in some cases
it can be like I got out of that
situation why can't you guys nobody help
me so nobody shall help you because I'm
[__] awesome I'm great I Rise the
buff now you if you can't do that then
you're worthless and don't deserve help
anyway uh it's it's uh it's really
really crazy here's this uh is this
would you consider this the Walmart
parking lot or where which parking lot
is this
which Trailer Park field is this uh
yeah bro this guy look this guy
for this is you know the longest uh
sitting uh U.S Supreme Court Justice
right now he is yeah really yes
and what is hilarious about it is that
his quote-unquote radicalization
according to him comes from [__]
Thomas Sowell and Ayn Rand
dummies read now and like he's like a
crypto podcast bro it's like it's like a
in the future we're gonna have Supreme
Court Justices be like yeah I I really
found my my you know I really found my
principles my ideology in The Joe Rogan
Experience specifically that episode he
did with Milo ianopoulos right yeah
um so this is of course
um Matt Walsh who is every week
competing to be the worst person in uh
basically ever to exist that show the
leftovers which is a great show by the
way thank you bro well he is good well
at least that he's good to us
uh here he is
um saying that uh we would all be worse
off if slavery never exists this is my
favorite including black people
it who's everyone
um yes including black people according
to him apparently he's done like a a a
big uh
big thing about how like white people
have been enslaved as well uh including
my takes about the Ottoman Empire
a lot of a historical comparisons why
people love engaging in these sorts of
things to like undermine how uniquely
horrific uh chattel slavery was it
always Loops back around to like well
white people are in slaves white people
were slaves in ancient Persia therefore
they blacks ain't got nothing to
complain about yeah so
uh you know it's it's just like
completely removed it's probably the
exact opposite of like uh historical
materialism but
um regardless uh this this clip I've
been meaning to get to on my stream and
I haven't so I'm very excited to cover
it all right let's do it here it is
trigger warnings the dumbest argument
you ever heard yes I mean yeah
obligatory I
yeah
that black Americans are doing better
here today than they would be had their
ancestors Generations ago never been
brought to these shorts this is awesome
we can prove this point by simply asking
which African country anyone asking for
reparations would prefer to live in the
answer of course is none of them now you
might offer the rebuttal that if slavery
never existed if we're reimagining
history without that institution can we
stop this hold on would you now when
you're talking that would literally
undermine he's like let's do a rebuttal
which would completely undermine the the
fake [__] that I just presented to
you like oh yeah which which African
nation would uh black people choose to
exist and it's like yeah that came
alongside the the inhumane practice of
chattel slavery
the the the colonial exploitation the
rampant exploitation robbing Africa
blind of its natural resources and its
humans is is
part of the reason why it was left
underdeveloped he doesn't go far enough
to ask the real question if slavery
never happened what would an ex and like
Colonial exploitation of Africa what
would Africa look like today Africa is
the most mineral Rich continent in the
world potentially the richest continent
in the world if they have access to
their own uh materials so uh that's the
real question to ask and I don't think
that uh you would be uh happy to answer
that one you guys have no idea how hard
you're about to be checkmated by him
okay all right fair enough fair enough
maybe we maybe we should stop pausing
and watch son wants bad stuff to happen
to black people oh [__] I got caught uh
your response I just I don't know what
to say I mean the the let's see what
this scholar has to say about uh you
know bad things happening to black
people in the foreign
would be better off there but this seems
highly unlikely and it also ignores the
fact that Africans participated in
slavery and the slave trade as much as
they were victims not to mention as much
yeah no definitely dude yeah no totally
they participate in the slave trade I
mean it's like yeah no it's actually
their fault not us the the people that
like purchased owned shipped uh the
these human beings it was the the
[__] tribal warlord one time like
that that's it's his fault actually it's
like saying that because during the
Holocaust there was Jews you know there
was famously Jews who helped Hitler find
other Jews well it was kind of the Jews
fault they participated in the Holocaust
yeah so I I would he say that though
could he get away with saying that of
course not no I wouldn't dream but it's
the same [__] thing Ben Shapiro he
probably what Dave Shapiro think about
he would probably say you know he he
raises an interesting point I I I would
uh disagree with him on just a few basic
little issues here but but ultimately
you know Matt's a good guy and I know
what he meant
yeah I'm just thinking of like uh you
know the the Capo narrative like they
they were the ones who were responsible
for the Holocaust
as much as they were victims of it yeah
it completely Psychopathic [__]
concept which Matt Walsh would of course
never entertain this guy is the worst
he's just the worst guy alive yeah
imagining the world without African
slavery then we have to also imagine it
without all other forms no we don't
slavery sometimes no we don't pause it
for a second no we don't first of all
you are making the hypothetical up so
you are the one who's saying you're
setting these boundaries and you're
making it seem like there's it's being
conducted at gunpoint it's like if we if
we eradicate Shadow slavery well then we
have to eradicate all slavery now it's
going to go to an even dumber
perspective from here like the jump off
point but I I just want to mention how
stupid this take is it's like no you
don't have to do that you could
technically Envision a world where
Channel slavery never existed I like to
imagine going where Matt Walsh never
existed oh dude that would be a sick
world where the Maxim gun was not
invented or was not deployed in Africa
that that like overpowered a lot of
these uh lesser developed very wealthy
but lesser developed uh uh areas it is
kind of interesting to think about
though I I do think about that what
would Africa be like without Colonial uh
exploitation I mean they could be
goddamn The Hub of the whole well maybe
not the Hub of the world but they would
definitely be a developed continent with
lots of resources yes it would be
significantly better off especially
considering unquestionably especially
considering their natural resources it
could be like a Utopia there I mean it
could be it could be such an incredible
Lee developed research or I mean a
resource Rich beautiful weather it's
like uh it's such a gorgeous place that
was absolutely destroyed by colonialism
and mount Walsh is like nah they asked
for it
you know it sucks too because Africa is
in need of uh
of help you know they need help to
they're being exploited by corporations
now and they need help to build
infrastructure to build roads to build
highways to build Bridges to build ports
and all this [__] and mount Walsh is
kind of polluting the well to the point
where it's like they don't need help
they did this to themselves like there
needs to be some accountability that
westerners take for the additional state
that Africa's in and you know except
that we need to help them develop and
not only that but it's good for the
whole world you know a healthy Africa is
good for everybody
and uh well it's not good for it's not
good for a lot of like a lot of
developed Western Nations that currently
still rely on
um
you know
neocolonial uh exploitation of the form
of like controlling their money supply
controlling their Banks controlling
their natural resources corporations are
exploiting them but like the world no
they're not corporations I'm talking
nation states like France has been there
pretty good France literally
controls the the central banks and and
pretty much the the currency exchange of
multiple African nations still to this
day they have their banks in France
like that is insane that is completely
insane but it's like it's just like
often gone unnoticed because nobody
really gives a [__]
um I mean this is a Michael parenti take
but there is no such thing as a poor
country poor countries are not
underdeveloped they're over exploited
and it's true uh they are stolen from
it's it's Africa's wealth that actually
made it such a robust Target and they
still are super [__] wealthy like
they're still discovering like Cobalt's
the most valuable resource in the world
right now for electric batteries and
China and America are just buying up
wholesale these masses in China yeah now
in the United States freaking out
because China actually owns most of it
now
and uh you know trillions of dollars
worth of cobalt and other rare rare uh
Earth elements
that could just like in the Congo no
less like it could make them one of the
wealthiest GDP or like per capita income
countries in the whole world like Norway
or some [__]
and but they're out there [__] you
know picking through the dirt with
pickaxe getting buried by excavators and
[__] and then people like Matt Walsh
Point figures and laugh at how medieval
they are how uncivilized and they're
just it's like you [__] you you [__] I
mean when you Congo is a great example
right when you think about Congo you're
like oh it's it has all these all these
natural resources what happened well
[__] Belgium happened you know what I
mean that's what happened they would cut
the [__] ears off in the hands and
and you know they would chop off the the
hands and legs and arms and ears of like
every [__] eligible working belt uh
Conga Congolese man it makes it hard to
uh develop
when there is someone who's cutting off
the limbs only only getting their
independence in like 1960. so anyway go
off Mount Walsh mention if we're
reimagining the world without African
slavery then we have to also imagine it
without all other forms of global
slavery since African slavery was merely
one variety one offshoot what are you
talking about what the [__] does that
even mean dummy you want to erase
slavery okay I'm down for that
but you're gonna have to imagine a lot
harder than you are right now to picture
what that would look like of This Global
Institution
and now we have totally in that point
Rewritten the history of the world in a
way so dramatic that it it's absolutely
impossible to say which individuals
today would end up worse or better in
this alternate universe I mean if you go
back in time and get rid of slavery from
the entire world
you have just it's impossible to say
what the world looks like right now
actually what we can say is that we'd
all end up worse all of us today would
you cannot [__] say that no no just
listening hard dude you're about to get
so oh okay I mean he's like if we go
back the one thing we know for sure we
can never imagine the outcome but the
one thing we know is that we're all
works off
be in a worse spot
if uh slavery never existed at all
across the entire globe
interesting because a change that
significant would likely shift the
course of events in a way that would
mean none of us would even exist it
would be a world full okay dub easy dub
Checkmate have you considered the
Multiverse Ethan that actually is that
actually is a Back to the Future moment
yeah bro that admiration from the
picture bring back slavery hurry yeah
it's like there's no reason to ever have
there's no reason to ever talk about
like alternative history because if
that's how you end every argument you
know what I mean yeah well the Holocaust
didn't happen you wouldn't exist like
it's like oh okay uh bring back the
Holocaust I'm a racing yeah like why did
you even engage in this like potential
hypothetical scenario you were gonna own
the argument by saying like Well
butterfly Theory you know what I mean
like what the [__] it'd all be worth
perfect we wouldn't even exist oh we're
racing
he's like a child this is bring back the
trailer this is the most this is the
most childish count this is the most
childish argument I've ever heard and
you know some dumbasses are going that
boy he's so right he's got a lot of good
ideas he's spinning
man he is dumb actually like so dumb
like yeah he's just hateful he's just
hateful and dumb and yeah Checkmate
atheists uh absolutely [__] owned you
can say that about everything
this is like a Rick and Morty ass
argument that is it's like what the [__]
are you talking about Dom bring it back
um so okay we love you
yeah why you would even bring this up
like if you were just gonna say well
none of us would exist [__] owned
like yeah I know okay
thanks oh I want to talk about this
North Carolina [__] so there was this
this [__] person okay she
um ran as what what was her office no in
North Carolina or North Carolina she ran
as talk about alternative timelines yeah
wait I I think that's the story we're
talking about right yeah you should call
them Democrat for house district 112 So
you ran as a house Democrat for North
Carolina she ran on a strict
[Music]
um
like basically part she was like
pro-choice
if you scroll down just a little bit
more on our website it it keep going a
little more
there you go here then here's what she
cares about building a fair economy
raising the minimum wage support small
businesses expand job training enact
Paid Family and Medical Leave she wants
to expand Medicare reign in Medicaid
Medicaid support health care workers
invest in child no she doesn't uh she
well here's the no the grossest lie in
that would you uh scrolled past is
actually the fact that she was um
as a former teacher and assistant
principal
[__] okay which school was she an
assistant principal of is very important
here but that's not mentioned in the
[__] article or in her website
she talks about
the the uh the equitability of of
funding Public Schools
she worked for a [__] charter school
that's all you need to know shocking
she's a charter school mom she's a
charter school principal and she snuck
into the ranks of the Democrats in a
deep blue District won it and then flip
the [__] seat I've never heard of it
disgusting but she writes like basically
she's Pro LGBT plus I don't see anything
on here about pro-choice but I heard she
was like uh there's a uh in the dock
there's a tweet of hers from uh from
last year during the campaign so she was
like hardcore pro-choice let's see uh
here's the Tweet about it
um it's still up it's still up as of
last night so she says now more than
ever
we need leaders who will be unwavering
and Unapologetic in their support of
abortion rights I will fight Dakota
fibro
and continue my strong record of
defending the right to choose so she got
elected I'm not even kidding I think she
got an abortion
uh if I'm not if I'm not misremembering
I'm pretty sure she actually got an
abortion and talked about it
so she is now that she's one yes she did
I was right yeah right let's see it yeah
Trisha cotham once spoke of her abortion
will she helped North Carolina
Republicans like she has gotten an
abortion she was a you know staunch
pro-choice Advocate clearly you can't
win in the post you know a Roe v Wade
world that we're living and you can't
win any [__] District when you're
like uh openly running on making
abortions more uh restrictive
um so so for her to flip this and turn
around is absolutely psychotic it's
insane I think you should go to jail if
you do something like this it's the the
most like anti-democratic thing you can
do hold on I haven't really even
explained what happened so she got
elected
on this ticket of being a Democrat and a
deep blue District yeah and so when she
wins then she changes party to
Republican
she states she's open to abortionist
restrictions
so she has essentially uh lied to her
constituents
lied on her campaign been elected and
she's just like a wolf in sheep's
clothes or whatever she whatever the
[__] the saying is and she's just like a
hardcore
anti-abortion Republican who [__]
lied her way I've never heard of
anything like this the cynical the
cynicism taken to to
to do this is not it's Kirsten Cinema
with lower Stakes like it's it's just
like that's that's what she's doing
she's girl bossing I can't say exactly
what I would want to do to people like
this even on YouTube I think I we would
probably get banned if I said it
but I'm thinking it
yeah and you can't stop me from thinking
it okay what but would the world be a
better place
no no it's just where I'm not sure well
certainly she should certainly she
should go to jail right I don't know
there's no laws this has never happened
before but it's so cynical like now when
people are running we have to question
if they're [__] like lying about
their old platform to switch parties
what the [__] is this [__] here she is
announcing that she's switching to
Republican and this is how long after
she won
three months uh yeah three months
if you don't do exactly what anyone who
has free thought
free judgment has Solutions who wants to
get to work to better our state not just
sit in a meeting and have a workshop
after a workshop but really work with
individuals yeah so this was obviously
like some really cynical plan from the
beginning to get in and be like the
Democrats they just don't work they just
don't do anything I need to join the
Republican party I mean
like do you guys
I'm sorry to think that they don't even
like democracy that much you're starting
to think that huh yeah you don't say I
just you don't say they really like that
fascist reactionaries don't like
democracy all too much to get things
done because that's what real public
servants do
if you don't do exactly what the
Democrats want you to do they will try
to bully you they will try to cast you
oh my God I saw that when I first filed
for office and was told why didn't you
ask for our commission
I didn't think I needed to do that as a
female
and quite frankly I was offended but
when I came back to this legislature I
knew times were different and things had
changed I also knew that I was different
I had been through a lot in like three
months and so
I am just different too and I'm proud
they didn't elect different you dummy I
I'm not kidding I because of how quickly
this happened and because of the
significance of this flip which offers
uh North Carolina Republican's power in
in the state
um there is speculation currently that
this might have been uh you know there
might have been some underhand uh you
know business dealings behind the scenes
this is what happened if somebody did
not speculate that like of course wait
wait if slavery never happened this is
what the oh no
I can't tell if this is objectively
worse or better I don't know it's just
different we can't possibly imagine the
outcome so like what Stephen Crowders
woke like is that was another woke yeah
or a guess or I think they're well still
lost his hairline though Big L
God Tim looks Temple looks fat there is
no there's no timeline where Temple
doesn't lose his entire hair
yeah I gotta hear this
it became very clear to me early on in
January that you better
vote in line with everything Governor
Cooper tells you to do from signing on
to bills
to he wanted to take your seat on the
house floor to your commitment it's been
three months all of this she's barely
got her like presentation her
orientation done
okay girl
and you have the full support of the
Republican Party
I have always been a free thinker
a woman of Faith pause it for a second I
just gotta say something
major once again
like the Democrats are responsible for
this okay they are like this is a person
that was not thoroughly vetted that was
backed by Emily's List by the way
another [__] incredible dub for the
Democratic party infrastructure
um this is Emily's List is a National
Organization that elects pro-choice
candidates
that the Democratic party likes against
candidates of the democratic party
doesn't like in their primaries Gotham
is listed as a co-sponsor of House Bill
19 a bill to codify the right to an
abortion up to the point of viability
which is about 26 weeks
um
and
I I have so many I have so many feelings
about this that I just cannot elaborate
on but
uh
it's just
it's yet another [__] up George Santos
was a major [__] up for the Democratic
party in a in a district that's supposed
to be deep blues like plus 10 Joe Biden
uh District where a charlatan liar was
able to just unseat the third like
fourth most powerful Democrat in in the
House of Representatives like one of the
major fundraising uh Democrat uh
Democratic Representatives they do not
care they just do not care about
protecting any of these [__] civil
liberties it's so obvious they are just
a bottleneck a stop gap for further left
politicians from ever reaching
prominence they don't care if seats like
this get [__] flipped because uh this
person was always a charter school freak
and certainly was never really like a
like an advocate for the things that
she's claiming a little bit a little
tiny bit
of background checking would have
exposed her
as a fraud for me it's like when I see
Charter Schools when I see uh charter
schools in someone's background I
immediately know where they stand they
are going to be a conservative Democrat
you know she does kind of riding the
George Santos wave though and where it's
like I can say anything to get elected
and then completely do anything I want
because I'm elected
very interesting strategy
and of Common Sense
I have always tried to work across the
aisle three months from day one three
months and I'm proud of that one because
that means we are what she was
previously uh elected like a while ago
like yeah
um yeah yeah no no she was back back in
like 2014 she was uh yeah in like a
different District or something oh yeah
she's not like brand new yeah yeah uh
right here we go uh she ran unopposed is
the thing
um how do you get that in 2014. I just
want to find me a district I can run
unopposed yeah it's they'll be like he
sucks he's [__] said all this
horrible stuff I'm like yeah well I'm
unopposed [__]
that's like the best gig ever working
together as Statesmen and States women
unfortunately that is talk in the
Democratic party that that's again
there's little action
and if I do that this is all about this
is switching this was just her giving
her like rationale because she announced
it the day before this uh and then I had
this press conference yesterday to uh
elaborate on her decision yes so um
somehow the Democrats being mean to her
made her think want to take rights away
from women
I'll get that don't quite get that one
again she was in Congress or in State uh
Congress left worked for again
uh former state representative Trisha
cotham a Democrat from Charlotte who
served in the state legislature from
March 2007 to January 2017 went
and worked for uh the one of the state's
most influential Charter Schools okay
that's what she did
when you see that charter schools are uh
quite the contentious subject matter uh
they are the most effective means and
the Democratic party absolutely always
engages in this they're the most
effective means of taking away
funds from our public schools and giving
them to unaccountable uh you know
oftentimes uh sub
optimal and terrible uh terrible charter
schools with the express purpose of
eviscerating teachers unions Charter
Schools often do not work with unions
they can get away with not working with
unions they can get away with like
teaching whatever the [__] they want at
Charter Schools as well they literally
take public funds and operate without
any of the same
uh operate without any of the same
regulations that public schools operate
under it's a fun little way that the
Democrats since the 90s have figured out
uh
they it's a it's a fun little way that
Democrats have been able to take funds
away from uh the public school system
wait absolutely dog [__] she's she's
also commenting
on this whole race baby uh basketball
controversy
it's awesome but this is her new Banner
it says uh trust God
I hope she finds God soon
right
flyers and I hate in her heart I hope
she finds God I hope
well I'll tell you there's going to be a
lot of angry people in her State who are
going to want to and rightfully so tell
her people who voted for her
who uh who who she's obligated to by the
way
um tell her what they think about her uh
Benedict cumberbatching
the
that's what is his recommended mm-hmm
uh thank you nobody's here to correct me
Benedict Arnold thank you yeah nobody I
thought he was playing
nobody was playing along I'm still in uh
you know I'm I'm in my feelings about
this freak this and this is Benedict
Cumberbatch monstrous freak
yeah she's vile I try to go to her
website it's just offline yes I hate it
is like is this a new thing now is this
not a [__] matters Ethan because none
of it matters like
it you know you always say like go out
and vote it's the it's the first step
towards like bettering Society it's the
least important most important thing you
can do yada yada and then you [__] do
go out and vote in deep blue District to
uh you know an uncontested Freakazoid
like this one and then she just flips
her seat
and I do think that the Attorney General
should Absa [__] lutely investigate
the relationship that this person had is
that your couch
it looks like it but no what the [__]
she's standing uh DeSantis yeah again
Universal school choice another way to
to bring about Charter Schools another
way to rob the coffers blind of an
already crippled public education system
everything that's bad about American
Education that you can point to you know
public education is bad because public
education is routinely underfunded well
let's hope she's investigated and goes
to prison right that'd be so sick she
can be like and now I can't go out to
Olive Garden without people just
interrupting my meals
[Music]
God damn it
anyway how do we how do we just not talk
about the main story well now we're here
finally the main story of today the main
story
Donald Trump has been arraigned Donald
Trump oh boy Donald Trump has been
arrested for what Ethan being the
greatest president of all time I'm not
even going to wait for you to answer
with your liberal ways now true you got
you saved me for myself yeah for being
the greatest president and executing the
perfect phone calls and being the best
at one having sex with porn stars and
also silencing them when he's running
for election Mike Lindell and Rudy
Giuliana are nodding in agreeance from
their now vastly improved lives yeah
look at me I had a beat off uh so here's
a summary he was arrested for 34 counts
of falsifying business documents which
is pretty juicy I see people saying he's
he could face a potential 130 years no
that's not true it's like four at most
and then but he's not going to do any
time probably even if he's good most
likely not but that's okay you know like
even if he doesn't beat the case the
likelihood that he goes to prison is is
very very very very low especially
because of the nature of this especially
because of the nature of the charges
originally would be considered a
misdemeanor with a maximum prison
sentence of a year which no one [__]
serves let's just do house arrest for a
little for a minute I don't even think
that that would happen let's [__]
real
probation most likely Unity service can
we get him picking up trash on this I
doubt it
um doubt that any of that would happen
Secret Service in him together could
make a pretty killer Cleanup Crew yeah
um prosecutors are accusing Trump of
orchestrating a broader scheme to
influence the 2016 presidential election
by purchasing damaging stories about him
to keep them under wraps in what is
known as a catch and kill scheme uh he
worked with the National Enquirer on
this I think it was Ami if I'm not
mistaken is like the the main company
that they work with there's a guy named
David pecker not related to Hank pecker
a famous conservative uh uh broadcast I
like that Hank Becker filler yeah not
Hank pecker Hank pecker would never [__]
up like David David is the [__]
traitor he's a star witness in this case
he's a anyway Cumberbatch yeah but here
here's a summary of kind of the case
that yeah Hassan's working on you you
want to read that sure the charges
traced back to a 130
000 uh dollar hush money payment that
Trump's fixer Michael D Cohen also a
friend of the show yeah I have been on
his podcast I don't know if you know
this
um yeah uh made to Stormy Daniels in the
final days of the 2016 campaign Trump
reimbursed Cohen while serving as the
commander-in-chief and that's where the
fraud kicked in prosecutors say
falsifying business records can be
charged as a misdemeanor offense in
normal circumstances but the elevated to
a felony the district attorney must
prove that Trump's intent to defraud was
in service of a second crime that's not
fraud
well I don't think ja rules should be
the authority on he's not the judge is
he
I don't I don't believe jaw is involved
he should he yeah Ja Rule should recuse
himself
prosecutors don't have to charge Trump
with the secondary crime but they must
show that there was a commit intent to
commit or conceal a second crime which
presumably is finance uh campaign
Finance campaign Finance violations that
Michael Cohen went to jail for but also
uh defrauding uh voters like lying to
voters so the prosecutors linked Trump
to three hush money deals suggesting
that the pay Mr Daniels was part of a
broader strategy to influence the
election the charges against Trump are
all classy felonies which is uh you know
they the lightest that's a felony like a
diet felony yeah including but not
living which I've never seen a skinny
person do by the way yeah uh including
but not limited to even paying uh his
doorman thirty thousand dollars to kill
a story about him uh potentially
fathering a child with a model
um
the the we now know that there was no uh
child but potentially there could have
been an abortion pays to be his doorman
dude because this [__]
notoriously doesn't pay anybody he
doesn't pay contractors
uh famously he tried not to pay Stormy
Daniels famously which is now being used
as evidence against them they didn't
ever pay her uh no he did okay Michael
and he paid Michael Cohen but
what's funny about this is that uh he
did openly tell Michael Cohen and the
other lawyer
hold off until after the election if you
can because
who cares if uh if the story comes out
after the election which is
uh being used as a as evidence to prove
that he was doing it specifically for
the election because there's a John
Edwards defense famously uh that you can
deploy in the circumstance to avoid any
kind of like legal accountability you
can claim well one I didn't know that
this was a violation uh which you know
makes this uh weirdly enough like if
your lack of knowledge surrounding the
law could technically uh uh help you in
this circumstance yeah and then two well
I didn't actually do it
I didn't actually do it uh for uh
defrauding uh you know voters I did it
not to Shield the voters from the truth
about a particular matter like my Affair
or whatever I did it specifically to
defend my marriage to hide this from My
Wife and basically you know make sure
that my marriage was safe and in John
Edwards case that actually worked uh but
in Trump's case there's a lot of
evidence to show that he didn't give a
[__] about anybody else knowing about
this after the election so it's a very
difficult thing to prove
they got pretty good they they don't
have an impossible road but Donald Trump
is the type of person who like does not
even care remotely about covering his
tracks and very brazenly is corrupt and
and operates in a mafia style scheme for
the most part but like the dumbest kind
of mob boss so uh he he basically left a
paper trail and also very openly
communicated to people that are now
Witnesses in this trial uh that he was
doing this almost specifically for the
election something really interesting
that's going on too is that Trump
famously has threatened and cited
violence against his uh detractors
for example the judge or was it the
prosecutor he posted on true social a
picture of them and then him holding a
bat
uh it was the prosecutor's brag did you
have that here I'll pull it up he also
was talking [__] about the judge
and during the first hearing here today
which which we're about to watch him
walk into
the prosecutor complained to the judge
yo he cannot be posting [__] that's
going to incite violence against any of
us and the judge said I agree
you cannot do that you should not do
that and so the thing is before when
he's suspected of crimes he can pretty
much do that [__] but now that he is a
defendant for a crime the court if he
keeps doing this [__] can [__] his life
up he issue a gag order uh they can hold
him in contempt to court
there are many different Avenues
obviously they can't really do that
because it's Donald Trump and you know
he's [__] former president but a lot
of the things that are happening
currently are unprecedented in general
help his case but this is that like you
want to call the Alex Jones move he's
pulling Alex Jones remember when Alex
Jones was like let's see how that works
out doing the deformation pull that back
up yeah yeah yeah and he literally was
like uh yeah your honor I yeah that's
you with you know looking like Satan yes
I called you a pedophile we'll see how
that works out for uh Alex Jones not
good not good for the case so he went
home after the judge told him to chill
the [__] out and posted this no this was
before this was the thing that he was
being called out for oh but afterwards
he was also posting yeah I mean it was
continued to post crazy ass [__] about
how he posted about the judge afterwards
right which is insane yeah not like a
picture like this but yeah attacking the
judge what did he say about the judge
whether a Democrat and uh they're really
fixated on the phone oh his daughter
daughter the judges water was part of
the Hillary campaign
uh something it was it might have been
Harris actually which LOL cringe that
yeah uh but yeah so uh here's Trump
walking into court so one thing
here let's show that and I'll tell you
some some interesting Parts notice how
the cop lets the door [__] slam into
him he's got yeah it's [__] up he
should go to jail that cop execution
idiot dummy loser
president Trump
also one thing I want to say that we got
on his arrest they took his height and
weight
oh dude yeah he was telling people he
was 6'4 and what was his way is do we
have that in here he's six foot one and
270 pounds I feel I've never felt like a
skinny [__] until I found out that
Trump has like 30 pounds on me that's
what he's gonna say is that if we need
to calculate it but I think Trump might
actually be [__] way fatter than I am
270 pounds how much do you weigh oh I'm
I'm at like 220.
God damn you are a skinny [__] and I'm
just saying like he's their Alpha they
love his ass but he's fat as [__] boy
you're just a you're just a lightweight
uh where is that part guys uh here
this was uh back in 2018 he was it's
probably six three 239 so where's he on
the BMI scale and I know you guys hate
that
yeah BMI is pretty [__] funny I just
want to know where's fat ass I mean he's
he's obese well pull it up I want to
Crunch the numbers okay and then I'll
crunch my numbers and we'll see who's
fatter out six one and he's 270 pounds
he has a BMI of
35.6 I want to see on this well over 30
is obese so it's well over that there's
there there's one website where it
places you on the whole spectrum and you
can really see how [__] they are I
mean I'm still obese my BMI currently at
249. the house is over is is still 30.3
so I'm obese listen the system is not
perfect I'm only doing this to humiliate
Trump
okay don't be offended this is just to
humiliate fat ass
Donald Trump
he's 35.6 on BMI what's wait just pull
up the graph and then we'll find his
location on it yeah yeah pull up that
one wait what just plug it in because it
doesn't he wants a graph I want the
graph it's important no I want to know
how let's do the rainbow one so we can
really color code it yeah so what do we
got here open that make that full screen
yeah so here we go so he is US meters
come on killer no it's fine it shows it
on the other side waiting okay inches
over here thank God he's six foot one yo
he's like crushing the the weight and
270 oh he's not even on he's off the
chart wait he's 270. yeah so he's just
all the way he's just all the way to the
right I guess the this Mark right here
is 270. so yeah and then he's a very
right he's six one holy [__] I guess he
I was hoping he'd be even more like way
he's not in the red but he's in the he's
in the dark orange here so so where's my
fat ass I'm 220. 220 and I'm 511. five
eleven
uh looks like you're right on the cusp
of the yellow fatter than me off the
charts he's fatter than me I mean you
could wait could have just my BMI is
higher than you Ethan what's yours see
that really tells you how much six four
wait how old are you I mean how tall are
you five eleven you said yeah that's cap
but okay what what's cap about that uh
220. you think I'm shorter than that oh
never mind your BMI is just a little bit
you gonna [__] come in here with that
tiny ass Dome and say I'm lying about it
[Music]
have we measured you first of all yes we
have and I measured when a b was here
and measured me I would I measured at
six feet but I don't use Stolen Valor by
the way the only reason people think I'm
[__] short is because I wear tiny
shoes if I bro you why why what are you
doing so how tall am I
yeah
okay I always say no one's five eleven
no one is five eleven I always say no
man is 5 11. you wanna measure me get
the tape measure [__] piece of [__]
get it out at 220 at 5 11 you have 30.7
that's your BMI because I am no I'm sick
of this height
because 49 pounds no no no no and I'm at
30.3 so your BMI is a great tad bit
where are you on the graph
I'm six foot four yeah 249 pounds yeah I
am at 30.3 on my BMI
yeah he's slightly in the orange you're
you're slightly in the yellow no that's
not that's not true I'm looking at the
BMI oh okay I'm looking at the BMI
calculator right now it says at 220
pounds
you are we're both in the Obesity range
not in the overweight range what's his
BMI if it's uh 510
you have such a thing about height
because people go oh you're so short I
thought you're so short and then
Hassan's out here being like I'm lying
about being 5 11. I mean screw you dude
we've already measured me on the show oh
yeah we have listen if I was in Shakira
I'd walk around with like big ass
platform shoes like five orange juice
I love platform shoes
all right so I'm going with shoes off
right shirt off yeah you can measure it
up here we go
the tape measure is not a great way to
do this I will point out but because
it's not you're not going to get it
perfectly straight wait I'll do it I'll
do it yeah
no no we need a tall person to do this
we need a tall person to do this
uh
back up a little here let me close all
this [__]
there you go yeah we can
there you go perfect step on it
he's so tricked
far
so why are you doing it then because
this song's not going to give me a fair
reading he's going to do it you think
he's biased of course he is
yeah
um he's pushing down on my head so hard
[Laughter]
okay what are you follow
like like you are at uh where is it I
mean you're definitely well understood
but I didn't say I'm six foot [__] oh
why why is it taking so long to decide
70 and three quarters I believe that
would be five ten and three quarters
just under 511.
so the question is do you round up yes
okay well then I guess
five ten and three quarters bro and
again it I don't care how tall you are
and you're wearing thick ass shoes like
who cares literally Air Force Ones dude
those are thick when I wear Air Force
Ones I feel tall as [__] screw you so
I'm 511 sit down and shut up dude
five ten and three quarters I mean it
depends on the day A B measured me and I
was over five eleven you know some days
you're taller than others right yeah no
it is early in the day though isn't it
that you get shorter throughout the day
where is that right morning yeah yeah it
gets shorter throughout the day I think
you're the tallest right when you wake
up is that right I I've heard that that
it's one of those things that you hear
and you repeat but you never actually
fact if I stretched out you know what I
mean if I did some stretches and stuff
I'd be fine I walked around I'd be stop
Ian
I would be five eleven I love the
difference hold on you go oh no wait
they they're showing how we actually
look like side by side oh no there's a
glitch with the with the effects hold on
let me fix it hashan do you really
expect me to walk around and be like
let's just say my exact height is 5 10
and three quarters you want me to go hey
guys yeah so I'm five ten and three
quarters I've never cared about this but
your reactions you're like six four bro
and you're just a little [__] ass who
[__] I'm glad you're doing this because
Ethan you you obsess over all of your
enemies Heights like to it okay so then
don't take it away then I'm five eleven
no but it's just it you're turning it's
fun to see you got a little taste of
your own mind wait because you do the
wrong thing you you're you're losing all
the filters
every single filter has been broken he
got even more realistic whatever tiny
ass head [__] I don't like it right
now does it
according to like a medieval scientists
you're like uh probably have like uh
those guys were raises though yeah
according to them you probably have
[__] some kind of deformed deformity
that I can't even joke about it anymore
microcephaly
it'd be funny if your voice started
changing like but if I was wearing shoes
I'd be like oh well over six foot
sure
wait I think I might be hold on
hold on at a
uh oh yeah no no no no don't wait what
happened
I'm seeing if I can put a little voice
filter on you oh no
all right well anyway we were doing the
news you know what I mean
so I'll write that
you can put it on but uh we'll just keep
on with the news
but uh you know you're such a dick dude
it's like a guy like you you're like oh
yeah I'm a honk I look like a model I'm
tall and then for you to walk around and
[__] on other dudes height no I never so
I never said it bro how old are we I
know you're so pathetic dude have some
humility humble yourself humble yourself
you [__] [__] his voice what
happened where did my voice go I gotta
Loop through something humble yourself
Hassan
it's ridiculous
oh who sounds like a little boy now yeah
I can't put it just on your mic is the
problems
rejiggering stuff yeah
that's a shame
um but you got to admit right now if you
were gonna round in in the words
no currency God uh I'm way more humble
than you dog I'm always humble
[__] on the planet dog so so you
know how to round numbers right what do
they say because you've been through
basic arithmetic and at school
um I think the honest thing you do is
say that you're five ten
what do they teach you in math school
what do they teach you in math which how
do you round a number
how would you round a number Hassan
answer the question if you have if if
you're a math class and you have 1.75
and the teacher asks you to round the
number where are you going to round it
yeah
you got it down yeah you're a dumbass I
knew that [__] failure dumbass
everybody knows you round that [__] up
to 5 11. and by the way I am five eleven
you just caught me on a short day
but being a short day but being five
but you know being five ten and three
quarters is fine because your hater ass
was measuring me and even you couldn't
deny you respect their fidgeting with
the numbers like oh oh good I can't like
oh yeah you're wrong that's why you're
taking so long you're like oh God I just
can't read these which way do I round
numbers I [__] don't know how to do
math oh God I don't know dude what does
it say since 5 11. douche oh Jesus
Christ tiny ass head
oh no
you want to know what you look like you
know what you you got real short with me
on on today's episode
hey Hassan
I really liked you in [__]
Beetlejuice you tiny headed little freak
[Music]
broad shoulders
it was a bad head day
yeah dude I really love you what was
Michael Keaton like because I'm met him
uh he was very he's wonderful
Class Act all right let's talk about
[__] Donald Trump oh man
I just was proven right so we gotta we
gotta figure we gotta fix the filters to
make Ethan
not look like oh finally there we go
yeah
we blew him up a little bit
sad baby sad baby wants a baby
all right
that's what I'm saying bro you can't
call me out on [__] Sebastian
crypto bro
all right where were we that was awesome
let me think about it hold on yeah um we
were talking about oh yeah that Trump
lied so he's fatter than me yeah and so
are you fat ass oh yeah no I'm no you
know I am bigger than you yes this is
true not fatter bmi-wise no BMI was yes
I am more oh no because we found out it
was more obese yeah sorry but you didn't
do it at five at five eleven he's more
obese than me okay okay so it works the
system works I just want to be left
alone no it definitely doesn't but
um
so anyway he's fat he's shorter than he
said yeah he's uh he's running around
claiming six foot three I think or six
or four on certain occasions like Ethan
says he's five eleven but turns out he's
six foot one
thanks
by the way we haven't even watched this
goddamn stupid ass video of him walking
no seconds can you show me the [__] up
so I can watch 10 seconds and
uninterrupted sure it's literally a 10
second video can I ask you to do that we
actually didn't watch this video
we did we did okay you forgot about it
because you got heated about it they
decided
uh here it is uh do a fake mug shot oh
they're selling this really yeah so it
came out uh before the arraignment you
should have let him take a real mug shot
it would have been cool I think the
Judge did not allow him to do that or
the judge said that like there's no
reason for that and that there were no
cameras inside of the courtroom they
took some still photos inside of the
courtroom
and there was a little bit of Court uh
you know the the the art that they come
out with God that is a horrible design
it's so bad yeah that it just sucks
because like it's like [__] he doesn't
look sexy yeah like this is not making
uh this is not making the mega moms hot
but I mean they'll fake it they'll act
like they you know think this is sexy
but I was very excited for a mug shot
I'm very I'm very sad that that didn't
happen
um you know this is they should have
pushed I think Alvin Brown should go to
jail so should the judge honestly for
that crime alone nothing else yeah fair
fair Donald Trump tweeted out or just
truth doubt republicans in Congress
should defund the doj and FBI until they
come to their senses that's awesome hey
Cat brother
another thing I agree with I mean he's
he's just spitting right now so
Democrats have totally weaponized law
enforcement this is the guy who's
attorney general was [__] uh Bill
Barr whoever the [__] that Flynn Fred
Flintstone looking ass
[__] guy was very Fred from the stone
isn't he uh MTG Magic the Gathering
the much cooler version of marger and
Taylor gross
is she oh this is oh my god oh this is
gonna freak you the [__] out okay let's
follow up have you you haven't seen this
before I have not seen this the
follow-up oh my God I'm so excited for
you to see this okay let's watch all
right president Trump is joining some of
the most incredible people in history
being arrested today
was arrested serve time in prison Jesus
Jesus was arrested she's basically on
the imagine if F if slavery never
existed yeah yeah I know Donald Trump is
just like Jesus he's a lot of bad people
were arrested too I don't know Donald
Trump is just like Jesus he shredded
sexy peeled sun kissed perfectly and
also being prosecuted by the Roman
government
and murdered by the Roman government
there have been many people throughout
history that have been arrested and
persecuted
you know what
shame on this [__] country for
putting this woman in a position to
actually think that she's saying
anything interesting like you saw that
[__] 60 Minutes puff piece that they
did on it shame on him what a [__]
let down so pathetic it's not let down
it's like understandable but like Leslie
Stahl no she [__] up
she all she did her only pushback when
she was like Democrats are pedophiles
and vampires she said unless he's like
okay don't you think you're being a
little silly
no and then and then she was like no I'm
not it's true and then she was like okay
moving on wow okay really that's that's
all you got okay
that is there's no reason to give her
this woman any coverage he's not
interesting she shouldn't if she was not
if there was not a cult that elected her
she she's just she's not smart she's not
interesting she's crazy like let's just
go pick [__] let's just go find the
most like psychosis people in skid row
and put him on 60 Minutes and ask him
about their politics yeah
yeah how do you like this
looks it seems fair it's just like but
you can't really tell how 510 you are in
that photo right because we're sitting
next to one another yeah well if you
count if you if you count how tiny or
actually your head is you're gonna be
five eleven
yeah no I think that our argument
actually goes to show that like imagine
there was no slavery even with my tiny
Dome I'm still 6'4
imagine there was no slavery Hassan what
now or are you you would not be alive
[Music]
that's a the Nook uh a legendary singer
called corrupt governments and it's
beginning today in New York City
um and I just can't believe it's
happening but I'll always support him
he's done nothing wrong president Trump
is so she's here to support Trump uh I
know where this is going she's here to
uh rally some support
um wait she's what wait what yeah wait
what the [__]
[Music]
they're dating and I thought where the
[__] is Kevin McCarthy if he saw this
he'd be so sad so all right punch in the
drywall Harlot so all right bye-bye you
Harlot margarine I I'm defending you for
you found out that you broke the heart
of Kevin McCarthy he's a good man
oh God careful date in a tight he gave
you committee positions he defended you
in spite of all the times where you have
said horrible things like Jewish space
lasers are responsible for California
wildfires yeah so Martin thank you for
that Hassan uh so marjor and Taylor
gross I can't believe she's not butter
margarine I can't believe she's not
buttered gross I call her Marjorie uh
Titan green because she looks like a
smiling Titan she looked that analogy is
just so perfect uh here she is arriving
in New York to much fanfare to the great
citizens of New York
[Music]
you filthy animals
[Applause]
[Music]
by the way so he's very good at yelling
at people he really convinced people
this isn't even his video a lot of
people thought he was there which is
crazy why would he be there he took some
dude's video and just screamed at it oh
yeah he wasn't there he wasn't there
bomber Rudy Giuliani nasty filthy sloppy
disgusting filthy [__] animal he's
right I mean he's spot on but now but
the crowd is real she was absolutely
drowned out she was trying to do like a
rally there uh she's drowned out by
whistles and protesters so she's
crushing it
us
a USA USA USA USA
Trump for Herschel my man brought wait
Hershel wait wait go back wait wait wait
wait lacks for Trump or Herschel dude
you got to get a new sign brother guy is
in New York with a sign for a failed
candidacy like what the [__] I love you
Herschel if they brought this sign from
Georgia they imported this sign that
that already happened brother it didn't
work
I love that they're like they're like we
can't be making all these blocks for
Trump signs just bring that over
it's all good for original that's
awesome how long are they gonna be using
that
it's gonna expire soon
love that for them
uh let's see she did an interview with
uh
Steve Bannon of course there's fantastic
uh Meeting of Minds here although Steve
Bannon is smart he's a psychotic but
no I mean he's not dumb like she is
he's not all that smart either I think
people greatly over emphasize how smart
he's not he's not brain dead like his
contemporaries
I mean he's he's as smart as you're
gonna he's as smart as you're gonna get
while being a [__] fascist
you know I mean if you want to compare
their IQs not if not that matters but do
you want to talk about the bell curve
we'll take a look at this
Checkmate or something I don't know all
right let's see what's perfectly singled
you out as a hooligan that's going to
cause a problem and that you're
dangerous and that you gotta back off
and go home your thoughts ma'am
he didn't just single me I do want to
say that Steve Bannon is probably the
most one of the most repulsive
physically people human he looks like a
human skin tag right so nasty right his
nipples protruded
worse than Barney Frank he's just vile
now Steve he threatened me he called me
by name and threatened me the mayor of
New York City I believe is is a thug and
he sent his people here today
you know yeah oh God I mean I [__]
hate Eric Adams okay he's a gigantic
[__] like but also very funny memes
uh about Eric Adams but uh and a
monstrous cop uh was a cop still a cop
as the mayor but like I know everybody
knows why Marjorie Taylor green is
calling him a thug yeah because he's
black hardcore dog whistle she hit the
heart she hit the hard t on that Thug
yeah
like he's a thug you guys catch what I'm
spitting here thuggish
nice text uh alert that went out calling
what I would say antifa to bring their
whistles pots and pans that was I'm
gonna call him antifa I like how she's
not even like they were into you but
she's like I'm just gonna call him
antifa you've seen that merch that
Herschel Walker uh blocks for Herschel
sign out there by antifa kinds of
instruments to make all kinds of noise
to drown me at apparently I heard that
all the whistles and [__] was actually
passed out by the cons the the Trump
guys I I know that I know that someone
thought that that was the case but I'm
pretty sure it was uh no it was liberals
that were hanging out I saw that one guy
who was like
not very coherent and he's like what no
I don't know Marjorie Taylor green I
like how antifa is like this existential
threat to our systems and then like this
big scary organization their their
counter protest is whistles
yeah violence whistling is violence
whistles it's about to overthrow the
snake
yeah so uh let's see
uh let's see here's a taste of uh some
of the
uh Trump stands outside the courtroom
we're up to the best and brightest as
always
let's take a listen so this woman is uh
this woman is trans
she is a transformaga really we gotta
get her a sign yeah
um Tran talks about it later in other
videos that I've seen I was I was
surprised
um she claims to be a trans Criminal
trans criminal yes wait what does that
mean he's like like I shouldn't exist
she says like no no she's she says she's
trans she calls sort of a transvestite
actually which is like super old school
like only [__] you know 75 year old
British uh trans women call themselves
that
um so that's also weird uh and uh she
also
uh says she's been to prison
and that she's a criminal but that she's
Maga she's going to Blair uh White
um
road to self-destruction
uh path mascara is not cute bye girl did
you have any other questions
wearing all that black that's soy now
foreign
all right interesting uh she falls over
the the antifa flag that they put out
there too there was like a like a you
know
Trump is a criminal sign or whatever
like a big flag that they put out it was
like here it is these uh wonderful old
ladies that go out and protest uh that's
not a trump supporter I know for a fact
that's a famous troll we should Michael
Picard oh this guy's just a comedian
yeah he you've probably seen some of his
videos he goes like just the pig thing
go to like pro cop protest and [__] on
cops I mean that's cool it seems like
almost everyone outside was a troll or
some sort like not many real supporters
yeah I mean there's a lot of real
aunties out there and not a lot of
stands not a lot of real stands out
there yeah very weak showing disgraceful
um I'm very what is this link because
this link says something that's not what
I opened Am I Wrong uh
uh or is it up
oh you're right it's uh the wrong bid
that's yeah it was got put in there
twice here I got it this was my favorite
video out of it there was one uh yeah
this was the only real Maga supporter
there and he had a really fun time I've
seen that even called into question but
go ahead it's still funny no way I swear
to God no way yeah I saw somebody
claiming that this this guy's a troll
too
is like a famous professional
skateboarder actually that's what
someone was saying
dude that was a good shot that's what
antifa had been up to huh that's a
Wipeout yeah
[Laughter]
yeah oh okay that's actually not cool
though does it kick the skateboard like
that I'm gonna denounce that kind of
violence
yeah I could tell you I thought it was a
mistake I mean who who knows how that
happened you know it's just I denounced
dangerous people around you sometimes
that was an antifa skateboard that was
planted the the Trump layup one is
really funny we should uh you know this
one here I think is what you're wait
it's the same one Dan
uh sorry I I pulled it up right here
I'll send it to you uh in the Discord
okay here we go this is about the other
uh
this is the same lady she's uh gosh what
is she doing
so she's a True Believer though we can
give her that
these are all old ladies that are like
this is the antifa Brigade that they're
talking about like a bunch of old a
bunch of old people that are like you
know NPR uh watching NPR reading
probably like probably give money to
democracy now you know 100 yeah like Amy
Goodman personally what's up do you
think Jeff teedricks went down there is
no boy guy yeah no no no no no Jeff
oh boy guy he this was his day wait
that's so there are more photos of him
yeah he's not he you know why he's not
out there because he's [__] unloading
he's doing come tributes to Donald
Trump's like fake mug shot who is this
guy I gotta know
I gotta know who he is
liberal I mean it's gonna be kind of I
want to know more about it before I
invite him on the show okay
did he have any Banger tweets can you
pull something he just had like that
where he just he just spammed laughing
yeah which you know what let him have
his day let him cook he hasn't been that
active I I feel like or I haven't really
seen any of his tweets since this
happened and I literally think he's
because he's like comatose from nutting
too hard
Nick Clark says look up Walter Masterson
I don't know what that is but he says
he's a good troll Walter mass is a troll
yeah he used to work with The Young
Turks too I think uh back in the day he
will go to these rallies and present
himself as a as a trump Republican and
like dupe people regularly
um
I love that relatively easy to do uh
lady
[Music]
you Vagabond no these are like Andy
these are like the the anti-war
participants from like the 60s that
actually did not become like anti-backs
or freaks right like those old ladies I
love those old ladies they're they're
you know they're great so there are True
Believers out there there's two of them
this would be my mom if uh if my family
lives in New York
yeah
kind totally you know environmental
protectors like they will go to like all
these different protests like they
antifa a lot of times we'll get arrested
by you know
uh psychotic private contractors former
military members that like literally
will torture them which was the video
you wanted us to pull up because I'm not
sure it's in here no it was just the
this is from the other court case that's
going on with the doj the classified
document and investigation
um
where Donald Trump Is His Own Worst
Enemy this one Ethan I just highlighted
it got it
um because currently there's the Georgia
case the Georgia RICO case which you
know Fannie will should probably [__]
stop
trying to arrest every rapper in the
state of [__] Georgia uh and instead
focus on this [__] you know what I mean
this is awesome where where Donald Trump
very openly said I want to to the you
know every single individ down to the
[__] number he was like I need 11
476 votes like that's pretty obvious
that's like pretty obviously criminal
that's a RICO case that's like pending
okay they're still investigating I don't
know what [__] investigation you need
to conclude there you have the tapes
um that one's a very real criminal case
in my opinion very serious one that one
should get him in uh prison hard to
dispute that one yeah
um there's that one perfect
films even say they'd be like your honor
it was clearly a joke it was a perfect
phone call there is new doj
investigations right now one is on the
classified documents and mishandling and
obstruction of of you know recovery I
guess of these classified documents
uh and then the other one is obviously
the January 16 Direction one and this is
Sean Hannity trying to but failing to
save Donald Trump in an interview where
they're talking about the document
investigation let's take a look at what
he had to say yeah
uh this sound seems to smeared off no
you just you have it turned on your
computer yeah or the video whatever I
can't I can't imagine you ever saying
um bring me some of the boxes that we
brought back from the White House I'd
like to look at them did you ever do
that I would have the right to do that
there's nothing wrong with it I know you
I don't think you would do it well I
don't have a lot of time but I would
have the right to do that I would do
that
he's trying to give a layup to Donald
Trump and Johnson's like no no I I have
done it I've done it so much I feel like
I've done so many times exactly what
Trump's doing right now where people are
like move on move on I'm like no I need
to double down on this except I'm not
I'm not at the risk of going to jail
right yeah just losing millions of
dollars to sponsors yeah
not yet
but you got to appreciate just what a
hack Hannity is because like you know
any serious journalist would follow that
thread but right him of course but he's
not it's not his job his job is to do
what he's doing he's like okay let's
move on let's move on right dude shut
the [__] up shut the [__] up how you
literally openly are admitting that you
looked at the classified documents and
like purposely were not giving it to the
feds you're right that is his job I
can't do that
to do that I would do that let me move
on remember this this is the
presidential records Act I have the
right to take stuff do you know that
they ended up paying Richard Nixon I
think 18 million dollars for what he had
they did the presidential records act I
had the right to take stuff I have the
right to look good stuff what does he
talk about Richard Nixon got paid 18
million dollars
I I don't know he's like Richard Nixon's
uh sold top secret documents for 18
million that stuff's worth something
someday I don't let me see if I could
dig into that
but they have the right to talk and we
have the right to talk this would have
all been worked out all of a sudden they
raided Mar-A-Lago viciously rated
Mar-A-Lago I have tape and I gave them
tapes you know I gave them tapes of
storage areas I gave it to them I could
have held that back oh I found it I
wasn't holding
the federal government has agreed to pay
18 million dollars to the estate of
Richard Nixon to settle claims that the
Watergate tapes and other presidential
materials were improperly seized by the
government in 1974 without compensation
he's literally saying I'm just like
Richard Nixon which is probably the
worst that what the [__] but that's
where the FED had to pay them money for
taking the tapes what the [__] is that
I'm talking about
that seems very weird what is that I'm
reading an article about it right now
I'm trying to sort out like why the
Nixon estate wanted 213 million dollars
for a three thousand seven hundred hours
of tapes and more than 4 million pages
of historic White House documents
I mean isn't that evidence like your boy
committed a crime
I guess they have a right to get it back
if it's his property but if he has
recordings from the time he's in the
office is that yeah are those official
records yeah at the time at the time
they were traditionally free to take all
the papers and other historical
materials with them into retirement but
Congress made an exception in Nixon's
case because he was the first President
to resign in a criminal Scandal so
Gerald Ford granted him a full party
because he's a [__] okay and and which
by the way LED to uh the the we cannot
hold former presidents accountable uh
not a precedent but like attitude that
uh the uh the American leadership has
and they gave him a full pardon and with
that full part and all of a sudden it's
like well the government no longer has
access to these tapes like we can take
it shred it destroy it all we want
that's [__] insane that we had to pay
Nixon's family 17 million though yeah
Trump is like
payday sounds good to me
yeah but it's it's 12 30 Hassan I know
you got to go yeah uh you're busy man
and uh we thank you
my tiny headed friend
you're welcome my five foot ten friend
Short came go ahead you can call me a
little person
my short King so anyway thank you
everyone for watching it's been a joy
it's been a pleasure tomorrow we have uh
Terry Joe what an exciting podcast we
have for him
so uh thank you for watching everybody
have a great day and we'll see you
tomorrow
[Music]
foreign